foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror my little book review series that
I have going on here
so I remember in the past I don't know
like year year and a half something like
that um I've seen like a lot of book
reviewers talking about Camilla sten's
you know internationally acclaimed 2021
novel The Lost village now it seems like
a lot of the reviews have been mixed but
mainly kind of tending toward the
positive and the premise at least from
like a sentence or two uh sounded pretty
intriguing so I was like well I don't
really care like if some people didn't
like it or not I'm gonna sit down and
read it because you know it sounded kind
of intriguing so I sat my ass down and
read the thing
and I ended up liking it uh quite a lot
now I can totally understand some of the
criticism too which I might get into
later but on the whole like I really
really enjoyed this very much I thought
it was like really really uh evocative
and like really atmospheric and I really
got into it so Camilla Sten is I think a
Swedish author and she's actually the
daughter of a rather well-known crime
writer named Vivica or Vivica Sten uh
the two of them have collaborated on
like some y a Thrillers and a couple of
other things matter of fact uh the Lost
Village was actually first published as
I believe Stodden was the name of it in
Sweden back in 2019 and has since gone
on to be translated into a whole bunch
of different languages 17 languages 19
languages something like that uh it's
also been optioned for film which
actually doesn't surprise me one bit uh
the story is very cinematic and it would
probably make a really really creepy
movie or probably better as a miniseries
uh alexand Andra Fleming by the way did
the English translation which obviously
is what I read because I don't speak
Swedish now in most of the marketing
that I saw for this book uh the novel
was pitched as The Blair Witch Project
meets midsummar which is sort of
accurate I guess as far as it goes but
it also kind of like sells this the
story short a little bit in my opinion
another weird thing is I keep seeing it
called a crime Thriller more than a
horror novel which I don't really get
because to me this seemed to sit very
comfortably in the horror Camp uh way
more than it did in the crime genre this
isn't really a crime you know what I
mean it's like when you think of like
Swedish crime Thriller you think of like
you know The Girl Who Kicked the Hornets
Nest or something like that this is
nothing like that so I don't really know
like maybe they're just it's just a
marketing thing like to try to hey if
you liked Steve Larson stuff like you
like this too because it's also Swedish
even though it's not really anything the
same but whatever I mean you know what
the hell do I know nothing
um maybe and honestly probably calling
something a thriller would probably like
attract a maybe a much wider swath of
readers than calling it a Horror Story
would because horror stories even though
like a lot more people read them
nowadays it's still kind of like a niche
market whereas Thriller is a lot more
you know has a lot more people that are
willing to read those I will say though
that in my estimation this is totally a
Horror Story
I have to say too that it deals with
actually one of my favorite tropes in
fiction which is an unexplained Mass
disappearance I love that kind of [ __ ]
and actually like creepy kind of [ __ ]
that happens you know like Roanoke and
all that kind of stuff that happened
like in real life like I really like
that uh hearing even though I think
there's I'm sure there's probably like a
really prosaic explanation for that in
particular but it's still like a really
intriguing like thing to think about ooh
what could have happened to them so I
really liked it I think that was what
attracted me to this particular novel in
the first place was I was like oh that
sounds like really interesting a whole
bunch of people like go missing out once
and nobody knows why so the Lost Village
it essentially switches back and forth
from like the present day timeline to an
account of events leading up to kind of
the central plot's disappearance which
happened back in 1959. so in the present
our main protagonist is named Alice and
she's 29 years old she's a filmmaker now
she's had some kind of like maybe mental
health setbacks in the past which they
get into and which kind of factors into
the plot a little bit but at this stage
in her life she's kind of finally on the
cusp of realizing her lifelong dream
project
ever since she was a child
she's been obsessed with the mystery
behind this Village called silvercharn
uh from which uh nearly 900 residents
suddenly vanished one day never to be
found uh they didn't find any bodies
they didn't find anything what ended up
happening was that when relatives that
lived outside the village like became
worried because they're like hey we
don't we haven't heard anything from our
relatives in silverchairn or anything
like that so they went there like a
couple of them went there to see what
happened and they found a bunch of just
abandoned houses looking for all the
world as though everybody had just
stepped out for a moment and never
returned like there was still like
coffee cups left on the counter and like
[ __ ] like that it seemed like everyone's
like oh I just went out to get the mail
or something and then shoot they all got
like [ __ ] raptured or some [ __ ] the
abandoned houses though aren't all they
found uh these two guys also found a
dead woman tied to a pole in the town
square and stoned to death
they also found a thankfully still alive
baby girl who was discovered in the
empty School uh they didn't know who the
parents were they didn't know like how
the baby was still there or anything
like that but uh there was no other clue
as to where everybody else had got off
to or what exactly the [ __ ] had happened
here now back in the 1950s uh you know
Alice our present-day protagonist her
grandmother Margarita she lived in this
Village which was very very remote but
very pleasant you know what I mean it
was a mining Village actually there was
a mine there
um and she lived there with her parents
and sister now Margarita when she got
older she eventually kind of like
married and she moved away like to the
big city she moved to Stockholm or
whatever but after she left it seemed as
though weird [ __ ] started happening like
back in silver trarn like the mine
closed down for one thing and that kind
of forced everybody out of work and so
there was widespread poverty and some of
the townsfolk like ended up moving away
but the ones that couldn't afford to do
that you know it they kind of got like
more and more desperate now for a little
while Margarita was getting letters from
her young sister who I believe was like
12 or 13 named Aina and in these letters
uh Anna Chronicles the arrival of a
charismatic newcomer in town let's just
say that not long after that though uh
the letters stopped coming and you know
not too long after that they found out
that everybody in the town was gone
except for this one dead woman and this
living baby that's inexplicably there
and they're not sure whose it is now
over the years after The Disappearance
Margarita had kept everything relating
to this mysterious tragedy in Silverton
including like all the letters from her
sister and like anytime anything about
it in the newspaper or anything because
it was kind of a big deal in Sweden
because it's like you know that's weird
as [ __ ] right now when she died she
actually gifted this whole big Treasure
Trove of historical information to Alice
because she had been telling Alice about
this weird [ __ ] to happen like all
Alice's life you know what I mean so
Alice has finally got funding from like
a backer who's also like a friend of
hers whose name is Max to make a
documentary about this incident which
she says she's been wanting to do since
she was like nine years old and she went
to film school so she could realize this
dream right
now coming along with her on this
journey to the abandoned town
is the aforementioned Max who you know
had kind of like made some money in Tech
or something like that and you know was
like yeah I'll back some of your project
also coming along is Emmy who's an
experienced she's kind of worked in the
industry a lot and experienced director
she was also Alice's former best friend
before they had some kind of tragic
falling out sometime before
there's also
um a young woman named tone or Tony I'm
not really sure how you pronounce that
uh she's a photographer and she's also
like a newer you know close friend of
Alice's she also has some personal ties
to Silver Tarn and then rounding out the
rest of the cast is Robert who I think
is like Emmy's boyfriend and he's also
kind of like The Tech Guy you know what
I mean he's one who knows how to like
shoot all the footage and whatnot so
this preliminary trip to the Lost
Village is only gonna last five days
they're not like making the entire
documentary this time around but they
are kind of hoping to kind of scout the
place out get some footage and some
photos that will help them to put
together like a promotional package and
a trailer that will help to get them
more investors so they can come back
later and make like the full-scale
documentary out of it Alice perhaps
somewhat naively I guess is also hoping
that maybe she'll come across some clue
as to what happened to all the residents
all that time ago that was somehow
overlooked pretty much from the minute
they arrived though
um things are like unsettling as [ __ ]
right like silver Tarn is exactly as
creepy as its reputation would suggest
and even though like Alice is very very
excited by this the whole like Eerie
visuals they're capturing she's like oh
my God look at this place and they're
like taking pictures of and everything
and I have to say too that like the pros
here is really evocative like I said
like when you first get there with this
crew and like the author is describing
like what it looks like I could really
picture this kind of like really creepy
forgotten empty Village just kind of
like rotting away under the Swedish Sun
like holding its secrets in it was like
really really I think it was like really
well written because I could really like
see it in my mind but uh they're not
there too long before tensions start to
mount particularly between Alice and
Emmy who have some unresolved issues
from their past friendship which they
probably need to sort out uh Tony also
starts acting pretty weird as the days
go by
and what's even worse than that is that
apparently maybe paranormal stuff like
starts to happen like they'll see
somebody like they see somebody like
looking in the windshield of the van
like well there's something they and
they're just like oh well maybe it was
one of the other because there's five
people there
you know what I mean so it's like well
we don't know if it was like one of them
or if it was something like that you
know what I mean so it's just kind of
like they think they see people but
they're not sure
um they also hear like weird noises over
there walkie-talkies like that sounds
kind of like screaming or singing or
something like that and they're just
like what the [ __ ] is it wasn't me I
don't even have my walkie talkies that
kind of stuff like sometimes when
they're exploring some of the abandoned
buildings they think they hear footsteps
footsteps like down in the bottom parts
of the bully so it's like [ __ ] like that
which maybe leads you to believe that
maybe the shit's haunted or there's
something going on
now also while they're looking around
Alice finds a few like disquieting
little Clues like stashed in some of the
houses you know there's some there's
like an unfinished letter which sounds
kind of weird
um there's like some photographs there's
uh kind of like a written sermon which
sounds kind of [ __ ] up there's come
you know really kind of spooky what
looks like child's drawings that kind of
[ __ ]
now at about the halfway point of the
book something kind of big and uh very
unexpected happens I mean I certain
certainly was not expecting it
um and it ends up like the the back half
of the book essentially like plunges
this hapless film crew into survival
mode that's what it becomes like from
that point forward and then Meanwhile
we're kind of going back and forth like
it was like the events of 1959 are also
kind of like unspooled little by little
as we the readers are slowly let in on
the series of events which led up to the
entire town of silver turn like
seemingly disappearing off the face of
the Earth so as I mentioned I actually
really enjoyed this novel a great deal
uh it was very compelling it was very
eerie uh and it got me like uh invested
in the mystery like really early on like
from the first paragraph uh the build up
of the mystery the build up of the
Intrigue was really really well done I
mean my eyeballs were just like latched
to the page waiting to see what the
resolution was going to be now that said
this was one common criticism that I saw
and I kind of agree to it like maybe
slightly but I'm not sure that the
solution to the mystery is all that
believable let me say that like there
were some aspects of it where I was like
uh well I'm not really sure if that's
how that would go but you know what I
mean so it was like a little bit
disappointing in that regard but overall
I didn't really mind that I think mainly
because the rest of the book was so good
and like so immersive like I said I
could really picture what was going on
you know and like picture this whole
setting
um I really love the concept of a
disappearing town full of people and in
general I really liked the direction
that camillusen went in with it so I
would actually recommend this to anybody
looking for like a more maybe spooky
atmospheric sort of read in more of like
the mainstream horror vein and I'm not
saying that to be disparaging I'm just
saying the book isn't super gory or like
super it's horror or but it's not like
super horror you know what I mean it's
not like real graphic or anything like
that it seemed pretty accessible to a
wider audience that maybe doesn't read
much horror which is maybe why it was
marketed as a thriller even though it's
kind of not so I kind of feel like if
you're just kind of like a casual horror
fan or you just like spooky books it's
like you'll probably like really dig it
now if you're real you know if you're a
real seasoned horror fan you might think
well it's like overly familiar or it's
like this movie or it's like that book
or something like that because it does
have like a few it does borrow a few
tropes that are like not all that
uncommon but to be honest it's just I
thought it was exceptionally well put
together
and I think if they ever like make a
movie or a mini series out of this I
think it'll be really successful because
that's kind of how it played out while I
was reading it like it was very Visual
and I could actually like see it and I
was like man if they made a good
miniseries out of this this would kick
ass it would be really really good so
that will do it for this tomes of Terror
be sure to like and share and comment if
you enjoy the content and I'll see you
guys again on the next one bye
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]